[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a topic
that has been bugging me for quite some
time
and that is how on earth did a gigantic
basilisk survive inside of the teeny
tiny chamber of secrets for one thousand
plus years hogwarts is big but not that
big in the chamber though extraordinary
doesn't seem nearly big enough to
accommodate a 50-foot long serpent we're
first introduced to the basilisk which
was the horrific creation of hogwarts
founder salazar sutherin in the chamber
of secrets basilisks are enormous
serpentine creatures the existence of
which can be attributed to their
original twisted creator a dark wizard
by the name of herpo the fowl a common
misconception is that slytherin created
the first basilisk where in reality he
merely created his own the same one that
resides within hogwarts secret chamber
of the many fearsome beasts and monsters
that roam our land there is none more
curious or more deadly than the basilisk
known also as the king of serpents
this snake which may reach gigantic size
and live many hundreds of years is born
from a chicken's egg hatched beneath a
toad its methods of killing are most
wondrous for aside from its deadly and
venomous fangs the basilisk has a
murderous stare
and all who are fixed with the beam of
its eye shall suffer instant death
spiders flee before the basilisk for it
is their mortal enemy and the basilisk
flees only from the crowing of the
rooster which is fatal to it the
basilisk was initially placed inside of
a secret chamber in the school because
salazar disagreed with the other
founders and their philosophy that
muggleborn should be allowed to attend
the school
salazar was a strong advocate of blood
purity and felt that only pure blood
witches and wizards were worthy of
attending the school
unable to influence the way that the
other founders felt salazar created the
basilisk in a last-ditch effort to
effectively rid the school of
muggleborns
knowing that he wouldn't live forever
salazar also put magic in place to
ensure that whoever was his rightful
heir would be able to control the
creature
q voldemort because of this enchantment
any descendant of salazars would be able
to communicate with the giant creature
via parcel tongue the language of snakes
those who are able to speak parcel
tongue are known as parcel mounds and
voldemort was widely known to possess
this ability
as harry potter had a piece of soul
fragment inside of him he also possessed
this ability which is why he was able to
understand the basilisk speaking
however just because harry was a parcel
mouth it did not mean that he was able
to control the basilisk in any capacity
that responsibility was left with the
rightful heir of southern alone tom
riddle when harry first enters the
chamber of secrets he's all struck at
what appears in front of him in stature
and just overall presence the basilisk
of salazar satherin is at this point in
the story the most intimidating
challenge that harry will need to
overcome
okay on to the tricky stuff presumably
salazar created the basilisk either
during the birth of hogwarts or shortly
before departing from hogwarts whichever
way you want to spin it the basilisk was
around a thousand years old when harry
encounters it in the chamber of secrets
which begs the question how on earth did
such an enormous creature
up to 50 feet in length according to
major zoologist newt scamander survive
within the depths of the chamber of
secrets for 1 000 years
don't they eat
according to newt scamander an expert on
the topic a basilisk's lifespan can be
considerable so long as they have a
sufficient food source
the basilisk of herpa default for
example lived to be over 900 years old
he also goes on to add that basilisks
will eat all mammals and birds as well
as most reptiles
the basilisk eating is alluded to in
chapter 16 of the chamber of secrets
when ron steps on a rat's skull
but the tunnel was quiet as the grave
and the first unexpected sound they
heard was a loud crunch as ron stepped
on what turned out to be a rat's skull
harry lowered his wand to look at the
floor and saw that it was littered with
small animal bones
what this passage suggests is that the
basilisk eats a lot of small animals
however i'm certainly not convinced that
a diet of rats would be nearly enough to
sustain such an enormous creature
differences in physiologies aside for a
second i weigh 185 pounds and need to
eat 3 000 calories a day just to
maintain my weight so i can't even begin
to imagine how many calories a herculean
serpent would need
furthermore insatiable hunger and
caloric needs of the basilisk would need
to be met day in and day out for it to
survive stretch that out to 1000 years
and that's going to equate to more than
just a few small animal bones as for a
cannon answer i think that the animal
bones are the best that we're going to
get however i've got a few theories of
my own
theory number one because the basilisk
is actually just a giant snake this is
reinforced in the text in the chamber of
secrets then it would be fairly safe to
assume that the basilisk shares the
typical digestive traits of a snake and
as it turns out snakes are able to lower
their metabolic rates by up to 70
percent which allows them to survive for
prolonged periods without food this
might account for how the basilisk was
able to get by on so very little
but if the basilisk is only eating a
tiny amount of food then how did it end
up growing to such a gargantuan size
well according to various studies on
snakes
their unique genetic predisposition to
continue growing has nothing to do with
nourishment you see according to these
studies snakes will continue to grow
even with a lack of food as they possess
a strong selective advantage which
pushes them to grow longer furthermore
because the basilisk is such a specimen
of a snake magnified in nearly every way
it's not far-fetched to assume that
these metabolic phenomena are amplified
theory number two the basilisk leaves
the chamber we all know that the only
way in and out of the chamber is through
speaking parcel tongue but guess what
parcel tongue the language of snakes is
spoken by the basilisk a snake
what this means is that the basilisk
would have had plenty of opportunities
to head in and out of the chamber over
the millennia that it was trapped inside
it's also suggested at least according
to ron that the chamber of secrets was
actually located under the lake probably
an exact quote
if this is the case then i don't see why
the basilisk would have had any issue
leaving the chamber swimming into the
lake to grab dinner and then swimming
back
avoiding land would also probably
explain why the basilisk went undetected
yes that's right snakes can swim
this theory that the basilisk would come
and go would also explain the location
of the animal bones between the bathroom
pipe entrance and the doors which needed
a password
theory number three the basilisk is
magic therefore trying to apply science
to it is completely nonsensical it
merely survives because it was magically
enchanted to do so
which theory do you guys subscribe to
did you ever wonder how the basilisk
survived within the chamber of secrets
did this question only bother me
leave a comment down below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live